if there's a prosecution of donald trump
for mishandling classified information
there'll be riots in the streets oh
lindsay lady g
you little [ __ ] listen this is
ridiculous this riot thing number one
they already did that they have already
tried the riot thing and it didn't work
it did not work they got their most
loyal supporters to come to washington
the gravy seals they tried this [ __ ]
they tried this riot stuff they've done
did that lindsay look this is the
biggest [ __ ] farce this is the
biggest [ __ ] fraud that has ever been
brought on our country is what they're
talking about here they're trying to
stoke up violence from their most avid
ridiculous delusional q anon supporters
to commit violence
to save them from prosecution and it's
not going to work it's not going to work
they couldn't save you from losing badly
in an election they're definitely not
going to save you from a prosecution
this is really [ __ ] dumb really dumb
i mean so dumb and almost smells like
crime from lindsey graham and others
threatening the american people with
riots a bunch of [ __ ] toothless trump
supporters give me a [ __ ] break give
me a [ __ ] break you done you done
called on your most avid supporters to
save you in in 2020 in december they
came on january 6 they [ __ ] literally
they [ __ ] on our [ __ ] capital and our
constitution to try to overthrow the
government to make donald trump the king
and it didn't work they think they're
gonna just be able to snap their fingers
and call for another violent
insurrection where
where mar-a-lago because a bunch of
dummies are down there in trump
underwear with trump flags waving their
let's go brandon nazi flags all over the
place you really think that's gonna save
you
you really think that the american
people are gonna put up with this [ __ ]
jesus christ the american people want
this [ __ ] fat slob to slink away they
wanted him to slink away after they
[ __ ] voted eight million times
against him more times i should say 81
million times to [ __ ] tell him to go
get [ __ ] [ __ ] off
we don't want you anywhere near our
government and
boy we we see why now he was a [ __ ]
threat to our security these ninja poop
nazis are defending this the former
buffoon as he's trying to justify
stealing top secret documents and united
states senators saying oh well they're
right if they charge him with the crimes
that he committed what get the [ __ ] out
of here that's not the most egregious
thing i think lindsey graham actually
said in that interview to be quite
honest i think it's all [ __ ] they're
just cat calling all these [ __ ] these
fat toothless trump humpers on social
media to post videos to be investigated
by the fbi because they're making
threats against the government like the
guy in cincinnati or detroit or wherever
the hell it was and then the people in
arizona trying to [ __ ]
intimidate the fbi with a bunch of
rifles get the [ __ ] out of here this
civil war talk really is stupid it's
really stupid it's really dumb it's
[ __ ] dumb
because really honestly the threat of
our democracy is not in a war in the
streets
it's not these [ __ ] people can barely
get off the [ __ ] couch and get a bag
of cheetos and their diet coke to finish
watching new jerking off to newsmax for
crying out loud let alone get out in the
streets and commit a civil war against
the government of the united states the
military get the [ __ ] out of here
the threat to our democracy is inside
our governments that's the [ __ ]
threat
the ron desantis the greg abbotts the
lindsey grahams the people who are
elected officials who are infiltrated
into our government who are [ __ ]
treasonous pieces of [ __ ]
so much so that they're willing to take
away [ __ ] rights away from american
people and the american people had
enough of this [ __ ] even in kansas they
told them no and i believe in new york's
19th they told them to go [ __ ]
themselves
in the special election where they where
they elected pat ryan and said no we're
not gonna put up with your [ __ ]
republican fascist [ __ ] anymore where
you people thin mail your your fascism
with conservatism you want to take away
rights from people it's not gonna stop
at women's bodily autonomy and people
know that people know that these [ __ ]
white christian nationalists these
goddamn america first nazis are not
gonna stop at women's bodily autonomy
they won't they'll come for their vote
they'll come for your vote they'll come
for your [ __ ] freedom and that is one
thing you do not do to the american
people is come for their [ __ ] freedom
and [ __ ] on it you do not do that we
strive for liberty here in this country
and the rights and our freedoms grant us
that liberty and when you start
threatening that we will push back on
you